[Music]
how'd you sleep
weren't tell what there Wilbur in Dallas
for Nutella okay I'll tell them all
right so we are partnering up with suave
and they have sent us a whole ton of
shampoo BAM
they've actually sent us all day I'm
here to Dallas or Fort Worth to be exact
to go to a NASCAR event today
and this is gonna be our first NASCAR
that ever so this NASCAR race it just so
happens me in Fort Worth this is only an
hour away from Dallas so we decided to
come all the way to Dallas and spend
some time with athletes over knock out
two birds with one stone
hey so imagine we appeared in the bed
hey how'd you sleep good at it going
between the bed you slept with the
grandparents sometimes your fallback is
anything else Cushing yeah yeah there's
some times I felt like I was Cushing oh
that's pretty good you can't Denise is
getting good all right I'm gonna get
ready
no you don't want to go go time never
run out of shampoo anymore oh the
evening sent us paste I've never used
paste in my life before my more of a
gelled man but try some pace today why
am I gonna like this pace funny story
about this whole swathes
foster [ __ ] where I put my parents that
I would be coming to Dallas they were
like oh you're working with this time
I'm like Slav and they were like what
slob you know hair products is ee-oh
suave
[Music]
you ready for your first NASCAR race
I hear it's really really really loud
yeah hopefully they get they get was
earbuds they say that you're gonna feel
the vibrations of the cars in your chest
[Music]
I've been to one NASCAR race before in
my lifetime and that was really little
like I don't even really remember it dad
took me just remember getting earplugs
and I remember like the really loud like
I just remember be going like this like
everywhere you know your little there
everything's like extra loud plus we
have like different frequencies they you
know the older we get and we lose
hearing we're game or just a would all
right so it's a windy day today from
here the layer it up it's kind of cold
out here Texas we're about to meet a
racer though we're gonna meet just an
out guard in just a few minutes nice if
you have any questions for a real race
car driver what made you want to become
good question all first timers right
here yes right here when there's a crash
do people stop the race slow down so
we'll slow down at this crash
about 45 miles an hour
[Music]
this crazy
they're flying has allowed imagine being
out there
we're like the inside right now with the
window of between us and you're not
there's gonna be like thunder
lunch here at the Texas Motor Speedway
[Music]
he's mesmerized by the card
[Music]
do you hear
[Music]
right on and these are the garages
there
so there's one out on track right now
qualifying the other one is it buffets
the back of court we don't ever want to
have to use that because that means we
totally screwed up the primary court
like I said we have enough parts and
pieces for a third quarter there is
literally nothing on the bar that you
can be able to find in this hole alright
so we are now going to that
[Applause]
[Music]
all right we are finally going over to
the race
[Music]
he'll start tip today driving the number
seven swap mill Charolais with five wins
this year from Riverton Illinois Justin
Allgaier
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right we are finally back from our
NASCAR race trip Thank You suave men for
sending me and my family out to watch a
NASCAR race NASCAR is one of those
things where I don't think I would have
explored on my own just because you know
people always make fun of NASCAR
watching cars go in circles having been
there now and I know usually you'd
really do get sucked into the fun and
the craze of the NASCAR culture once
you're there and had a blast and
definitely looking forward to going to
another NASCAR race
[Music]
all right so we are going on a morning
bike ride today so they relieve pinellas
we're just gonna wind down and spend our
last day here with family yeah a fun
isak yeah we should get bikes too and in
LA what these kind of oh you went years
huh by the next bike we get you we're
gonna be getting gears you go faster on
them huh
then you should get three
all these are foldable oh that's nice I
like it yeah Tiffin I we've been
contemplating um buying bikes and stuff
but we don't know what kind of bike
they're enough we're gonna want to do
more like mountain bike you type stuff
or beach cruiser type stuff around like
crazy about bike riding you're probably
not going to get a specialized bike like
that so I mean this beast both of the
bikes seem to kind of do the trick
so foldable bikes mom that's rope thrown
up my parents used to love bike riding
Oh
muddy then you get that fight dirty
Isaac whoa you stopped it in the mud a
word of advice if you're riding a bike
and you're going to the puddles you
should go slow because this gonna splash
up and you're gonna get yourself all
dirty because I went really really slow
over the puddles and stuff yeah these
brake roads are really nostalgic because
growing up my parents loved riding bikes
and stuff and it was almost like a
family tradition to go out every Sunday
you take our bikes out and go bike
riding fly kites and barbecue has a
local park so doing this right now and
mom again and bringing Isaac around is
uh
her - cool cool designs on your wheels
Isaac
[Music]
okay so on our way back for the house we
decided to pay Carey and Diana and visit
at their house and my mom's living up to
her Everybody Loves Raymond in
comparison to the tea right now there's
Marie trying to figure out how to get
into raper Owens house all right so this
is everybody loves Carrie hi Raymond no
Carrie are you hungry
what does he say I don't know I just
know he has that nasally voice you live
near Robert okay he's the daughter how'd
you get there so fast oh yeah all right
I guess I don't need to tell you this
but don't fall okay all right so went
back to my parents house to get ready
for the day we're all packed up to head
back to LA now we stopped over at my
brother's house to hang out I guess
[Music]
can you like us so Vivi my brothers cat
is known to be a little feisty never
likes being touched especially by
strangers like us
Monty we've seen you for like the last
how many years five six years yeah we've
known each other for six years baby
[Music]
hit her face shatter - yeah I think do
you want to have a backyard like this
yeah yeah me too you're getting a house
now like it's great motivation for me
and tips I want to save up and get a
house to now do it it's we're not gonna
have a big yard like this though most
like they're not but but you just want
your own four walls that's not connected
to it yeah yeah
[Music]
we're getting a house Isaac wants a
backyard it's a dream we're never gonna
achieve lamellae I like this though this
is all right off to lunch and before we
leave Texas obviously there is a
mandatory barbecue feast that you have
to have yeah we'll take all the food and
none for them first play without sauce
to test the smokiness here we go
I wish I could eat this every day oh my
goodness this is like the best pumper
I've ever had in my life fresh out the
oven waited 20 minutes for these babies
crunchy on the outside so soft in the
middle
all right we are now at the airport
headed back to LA
[Music]